gang the middle class famous tour is
about to be in full effect come out and
see us it's a great way to introduce
some new people to the show so grab the
homies grab the ladies the birds the
bozos everybody and come see us yeah
guys we're going to be in hartford
albany syracuse atlanta tampa orlando
pittsburgh buffalo we ain't done yet
detroit denver phoenix salt lake city
chicago then over there to roseman and
that's just the first leg of the tour
gonna be coming so get the techies we'll
see you there welcome to another
exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley hey
everybody out there and welcome back to
everybody's favorite new podcast this is
ru garbage sure is it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're grouped to be
classy yeah or if they're just a big old
piece of trash i'm your host dave
trolley coming at you on a beautiful day
down here at antony's basement have not
seen her in a couple of days since the
eagles loss yeah which is usually how it
goes they win you don't see her for a
couple of weeks they lose you don't see
her for three or four weeks
i don't know what she's doing
anyway my co-host is coming at you from
across the table at me it's a family
episode we're circling the wagons we're
getting into it we're chopping up we're
doing the bills that's what we're doing
oh man remember that oh
do i shoebox full of keepers nobody's
saying that nobody say a word dude it
was just a shoe box full of red red
slips on the table [ __ ] past due
bills
give it up for kj kevin james ryan
everybody yeah hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure you
rate review subscribe on itunes full
video available on youtube and as you
know those numbers are true the roof
[ __ ] cooking baby and then obviously
we have to by law we have to mention at
patreon.com ru garbage you can sign up
your bonus content episodes of ayg
episode's a hard feeling which is the
runaway of the i feel that's gonna have
a big 2022. smash hit smash hit beaton's
doing spider-man numbers over there for
your consideration hard feelings yes sir
uh and then live streams with the top
tier members check it the [ __ ] out also
live shows we're going on a road all
over the place middle class famous tour
check it the [ __ ] out yes please do and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good yeah
t-bone mcmuffin toby mcmullen what's up
dudes toby i was going to say something
i'm off i don't like that intro the
whole thing the tootie stunk
i threw at the t-bone that stunt sounds
like he got into gesture damn it sounds
like he got some [ __ ] kimbasa working
overtime
i got a big case of the salami burps
i feel like i'm in a tums commercial
you're just you're one second away from
breathing out fire
somebody get this guy some milk of
magnesium something's that get him a
glass of two percent tubby you need a
rollaid's what's going on yeah too many
onions in my greek salad this morning
that's what happened how many onions in
my cereal you believe that
i said frosted flakes you jerk off
too many onions in my greek salad
they're coming back to haunt me a little
bit yeah nice greek salad today that's
nice
back to the bills though sure that was a
dicey sunday that was a sunday afternoon
patty would sit down she'd break the
book out break she had like a uh yeah
like like like a a you what's it called
a visor and an old-timey
machine no no no one of those one of
those things that like opens like an
accordion like one of those decks oh
yeah an accordion fight yeah yeah
she'd break that thing oh really ours
were in a [ __ ] reebok classic box
a blue a blue reebok box what with a
fresh set of kensington cruisers that
just popped out of them
look at that and we never probably cut
probably some cash in there too
couple yeah
my mom used to say we're house poor uh
you could just afford to live in the
house and not pay for anything
um
damn and she wouldn't do it on the
weekends that was a week you don't want
to ruin a nice sunday you know what i
mean
there's no good news coming
once that box gets out of the closet i
feel like patty did it on sunday before
dinner i remember before she started
cooking man you [ __ ] minded your p's
and q's yeah over those two hours you
didn't say a [ __ ] word uh-huh god
forbid your name's on one of them things
[ __ ] braces you [ __ ] son of a
[ __ ] crooked too small dick
[ __ ]
who you've been talking to
oh man if your mom ever called you a
little [ __ ]
you don't recover from that
straight straight straight to the bridge
put some rocks in your pocket jump
yikes that's a tough one
[Laughter]
anywho
anyhow um
good to see you buddy you too man
mike snyder toby's mike's off man stinks
charlie we're going through it
t-bone's hanging on by us by a long hair
[Laughter]
um what what do you got something
happened at the house i wanted to
discuss with you i don't know how gross
you're going to think it is
it's not that gross what house your
apartment my apartment yeah you call
that the house yeah what do you the [ __ ]
we think i call it
i don't know
yeah my house it's my house
no it's by definition not a heads of not
a hat my home at her home
i would say we're going back to the
house yeah we're going back to the house
after the bar we're gonna have a couple
beers back at the house i would say my
place back at my place or the crib the
crib the crib well you're not bringing
anybody back there anyway bozo so it
doesn't matter
no my my landlord said no parties after
11. now back to my place sure um we'll
call it the place to be
the house is it that's not the house the
house is your i thought immediately i
thought of your parents house okay if
you got an apartment you're calling the
house you're a bizarre
back at the apartment yeah or my place
my place all right all right i'm taking
my place okay where's your watch by the
way i only wear it on special occasions
i almost broke out the chain today
say that for hard feelings well i know
you're not breaking out no chains i have
the huge cuban link chain you've seen
this yeah but that's a joke
is it
okay i'm a comedian folks
guys you better not see me even neta
tavern next week this guy's you got
watches
you're getting fat
not no more hair's growing in
i don't know what's going on and you got
this going to the 5 o'clock shadow
so you're calling you're i said let me
get this straight you're this is very
hard feelings but you're claiming
[ __ ] watches and facial hair now and
and obesity well obesity someone's got
to be rich you're right
i'll i'm going to lose 15 pounds but i'm
keeping the watch somebody's got to be
rigged somebody's got to be murtaugh you
can't both be murtaugh can't both be up
here with is like ghost bit somebody's
got to be somebody's got to be riggs
okay i don't know what show we're
talking about to be honest with you
we're talking about lethal weapon and i
am clearly rigged
you're what i'm a loose cannon no you're
not riggs i'm
what you're big you're too old for this
[ __ ] literally yeah it's true all right
i could be mertoff
let me hear your danny glover
i just did it where i go spit
it's pretty good right i'm not a cop
killer
cop killers another baby cop killers
[Laughter]
[ __ ] love danny glover that'll yeah
okay
he's gonna go my way with me
you're just doing cotton
cotton's very danny glover he is they
were
he was very danny glover
man him at the end of the original
lethal weapon when he's out there not
with his in his underwear he's got a
little 38 special and a grenade that's
it trying to get his daughter back from
[ __ ] mercenaries that's what i'm
[ __ ] talking about where are those
guys
[Laughter]
i'm no murtaugh i can tell you that i'd
have been blowing every one of those
dudes
even with the cameras
[Laughter]
movie or no movie i'm blowing you they
all had sunglasses and oozies and [ __ ]
like that oozies were big in the huge
somebody has that bit it might have been
fellaini or somebody everybody had an
uzi and everybody was a terrible shot
dude a hero would run into a run into a
factory for a drug bust there'd be 15
guys in the rafters with oozies and now
one of them would hit that's a good
piece of business yeah what was with
that what with the uzis everybody loved
doozies back then and those mac nines
those were big you know what i'm talking
about mac 10. mac 10 i'm sorry mac 11s
whatever
sounds like something mcdonald's has it
every fourth of july sure
strikeout all right so you're back at
your house yes my place
um
we're usually uh truth be told
what's it called uh sensodyne we're a
sensodyne toothpaste sam really yeah
stuff works wonders wow yeah
really that blows you away that much for
you why i don't know i figured you use
lava soap or whatever
that go jack soap with the sand in it
cascades
um i feel like sensitive comes with that
blue liquid you put your toothbrush yeah
it's very medicinal
i don't get it to be not sensitive i
thought he had to
have a periodontist [ __ ] prescribe
that yeah well my mom we're used to
working the field back in the day um
work in the field she used to work in
dentistry oh she was a farmer
[Laughter]
anyway we got to scoop on that stuff
anyway she worked in dentistry
she she was an office manager okay of a
dental office you made it seem like she
was like you know running out of the
room when they were taking the x-rays
proctor and gamble
she worked in dennis she invented the
root canal i don't know what to tell you
um
anywho
um i was just just made me think there
was a time
probably about three or four months one
winter where we used exclusively
baking soda not baking soda toothpaste
but there was no toothpaste it was just
baking soda
for a minute she got on a real just like
that we would do just that we would do
that to one we did boat for a while for
a while talk about burning your taste
buds off that stuff gets on the tongue
it's a wrap you don't have to sit there
like a [ __ ] whoo good luck having a
gatorade for the next six months yeah
jesus felt like you're detailing a car
or something dude that [ __ ] was tough
i remember looking at the back of it and
they were like yeah you can clean your
rims with it i'm like what the [ __ ] am i
doing with this [ __ ] in my mouth then
this is a [ __ ] setup set of 22s in
your grill
instead of spinners
uh
yeah that's crazy i mean that's another
90s real 90s bit but like you can you
that shit's everywhere and there was one
box that like lasted that was in my oh
yeah in my bathroom four it's probably
still there
dip your toothbrush in there rattle it
around they they have to come up with a
better box for that [ __ ]
it's so whack
that [ __ ] cardboard jesus christ what
are we [ __ ] little orphanage were you
one of the families that had it in the
fridge
you're goddamn right it keeps the smell
away fridge and freezer no we know it
worked like a charm you got to run a
tighter ship then and she and she went
and then she no she ran a tight
say what you want about patty her
her fridge was tight there was never any
of that [ __ ] you everybody you don't
need to bake
that's how on-point she was that's how
on-point she was she would add one of
those right she forgot to buy toothpaste
what are you talking about no she was
just big into it i'm telling you but let
me ask you this do you ever go to a
buddy's house and you open their fridge
and it
[Music]
puts there's like old [ __ ] in there
uh-huh well i mean like i'm not yeah i
mean before pay out was always the clear
sign if i saw a takeout in a friend's
refrigerator i knew things weren't going
well
if there's multiple takeout boxes from
like yeah different places or whatever
yeah kid needs a home-cooked meal if you
got chinese and indian at the same week
who's helping you with your homework
that's what i want to know young man
yeah that's a tough look so listen as i
said where are we oh the sun's down
we're not even okay sensodyne you're a
sensodyne you're a sensodyne we're
sensitive
yes mostly because
my teeth will start to hurt if i don't
use it a little bit uh-huh to a little
bit of a degree sure all right i floss
every day but let's not i mean listen it
is what it is sure right
um
i didn't notice it
okay
but uh over the last couple of weeks
there's been a crest scope in there
or not crest it's some company
that has the scope in it you know what
i'm talking about who's ever rocking
that right colgate maybe it's pretty
tight because i'm a big scope guy
huge scope love scope when i was a kid
couldn't do this yeah it's crest with
scope that's all that'll do that's nice
that'll get you through in a pinch i
like the hard stuff i've never seen it
before though and it's really it's a
huge tube
never i've never listened i'm a weird
guy but there's nothing better in your
hands than a fresh tuba toothpaste
unsqueezed
good
night yes there's something it's
something to take a big saucy it's like
popping a bottle of champagne i feel
like a [ __ ] rich guy
um that lasts for about two days by the
way and then it's [ __ ] it's terrible
it's all over the place so this is kind
of a two-part question i wanted to ask
you
so i've never seen this tube of
toothpaste on my light before all right
it's a big one too it's a family a
family-sized [ __ ] jawn okay it's
about three quarters of the way done too
oh boy i don't like where this is going
and i'm using it and i'm using wait so
you just stumble upon
empty yeah but was it there i'm just
saying it wasn't yeah i didn't i didn't
realize it's after using it for like a
week or so
that like wait where the [ __ ] did this
come from oh boy
so we had some we had some family stay
with us
okay over the holiday sure um i guess
they had left it there okay probably
can't fly with it can't fly with it
unless they're checking back whatever
and we used it now i'm a pretty big dirt
bag as we we've all we all know that
right it's on the record i don't need to
stand on airs in here t-bone can you
reaver back the report is he a dirtbag
it's wild in there
but
how do you feel about because using
you know i'm a weird guy hold on we
brush our teeth in the shower we do this
we do that
how do you feel about using somebody
else's toothpaste because i don't know
about you when i put that toothpaste on
they're they're kissing
i'm not airdropping it they're
i was scraping it what are you steve
jobs no way you're air dropping it
you gotta go so i'm brushing my teeth
and i realize
i'm like oh [ __ ]
i've been using it for [ __ ] two weeks
i wouldn't do it unless you're like in a
pinch one time i wouldn't i wouldn't do
it yeah that would be that would be
trashed immediately in my house for sure
now let me ask you this there's just too
much it's too intimate the mouth
brushing your teeth i'd kiss if not have
your own two say it was my cousin i'd
kiss my cousin before i used the
toothpaste repet it like a whole tube
that's way too much it's way too much
i'm listening i'm talking about my
cousin liam by the way
good looking kid yeah um
and do you put the cap on your
toothpaste
yes you do typically yes capped up but
that thing you know i've noticed that
it's like a chromie the neighborhood
kids come and take them sometimes and
they don't always last the whole
duration yeah but i've noticed the
toothpaste is the cap is never on so i'm
just grabbing it raw dogging it
that's a little too much for me i'm a
germ guy that's uh
once if you're in a pinch i get it but
to habitually use it
yeah
i threw it out this morning not that i
don't love my relatives that stay don't
get me wrong who would ever no one would
ever assume that in the world okay
that's your paranoia kicking in i i
don't i don't want this to get back to
anything i don't love them because i
won't mouth kiss them
[Laughter]
i almost choked
did you guys you guys remember that it
was out for a little while that crest
where it would come out two different
types yeah we had that i think we had
the knockoff version of that it was like
a it looked like a rocket ship yeah like
you were mixing sealant yeah it looked
like a rocket ship they got real kooky
in the in the early 2000s with the tooth
the standing toothpaste that you press
down on get out of here with that my
buddy had that
that was like you were in i think that
was sensodyne thing you know you're
jerking off with it that's hey crazy
nine out of ten doctors recommend
my cousin had the worst version of that
where you take the tuba toothpaste and
put it in a little holder that has a
like a metal rod that goes through it
and then your wrapper wraps around the
toothpaste and then you turn that and it
goes up and it squeezes my friends now
have that and they're like yeah it's i
don't that's get out of here what you do
it on the side of the counter like a
[ __ ] side of the sink like a
gentleman what do you mean you take and
you [ __ ] slide it down to get the
rest out
oh i thought you meant normally normally
you pick it up and squirt it on your
toothbrush yeah but i'm saying when it
gets low yeah take it and [ __ ] it
of course have you ever cut the have you
ever cut the tube we've discussed this
yeah we've got i've cut i think i've
done it in a jam like on vacation in a
hotel room or something where i'm like i
i need a little bit yeah
you ever see the ones they give you at
hotels the little little tiny tiny
little baby ones i don't think i've ever
it's for like you get two you get you
get like one shot at it yeah no i don't
think i ever did that
i'm not one of those guys that go down
and be like hey i forgot my deodorant do
you have a sewing kit or whatever oh
really i'll buy it if they have it in
the store and i need it
i have some what do you ask them no
really
so you're not gonna brush your teeth
what if they don't have it at the place
at the at the card store downstairs or
whatever it's called
they typically do that they they don't
they're out well they don't what are you
doing
i'm knocking on my neighbor's door see
if i can die yeah no i don't know at a
hotel you're knocking on me no i'm
kidding you [ __ ] idiot well what why
is there going to be a store in a hotel
and they don't have [ __ ] toothpaste
because of the supply chain no you're
wrong
they're outsourcing you're spilling your
tea everywhere by the way i'll spill a
little tea i'll tell you a little story
yeah
all right let's get into some [ __ ]
questions here let's get into it gang as
you know when you sign up for the old
patreon patreon i got a question uh read
on the air and it's a good time we're
having fun over there yeah uh but let's
see here what do you want to start off
with
let's do all right this is from civilian
civic whatever
uh do you constantly finish your dinner
dinner in under five minutes
it's i
as much [ __ ] as i give you for being
gross and disgust i eat like i'm in the
military it's like
i'm doing a job while i'm eating and
it's like you're making room for it's
going i'm taking a sip to clear the
pipes so i can get more in we had dinner
together not that long ago we both did a
pretty good job
of standing on airs of
you know we carried a conversation we
weren't animals yeah to a degree also
drinking too so sure yeah but i know
exactly what what they mean
i look at people like even when i was
waiting tables i would like watch people
like eat and like they're having like
nice conversations my wife does it
they're like sitting back the guy's got
his legs folded he's drinking his wine
and but it doesn't seem like three hours
but it seems like
like they're having just a nice time i'm
[ __ ]
lit
yeah i'm i'm stuffing it in well they
should they say like chew every bite
like 20 times or something that's
[ __ ] old lady crazy [ __ ] is it a dude
i i guarantee you there's not a guy out
there who's 400 pounds who's counting to
20 every time he's chewing i'm like two
bites
yeah no it's yeah like a lioness
um it's tough but my dude
i get self-conscious with it because my
wife is so methodic with it of like
cut this
a little bit of the mashed potatoes
throw a half a pee in there little [ __ ]
nibblet of corn
and i'm like [ __ ] all while carrying
adult conversations yes yeah about about
about a wide variety of topics meanwhile
i'm on instagram shoving a chicken bone
in my ass it's [ __ ]
i get after it i think that has to do i
don't know but this is hold on this is
and she goes like she'll say like
[ __ ] chill and then i'm in my head
going
and i'm like this isn't me enjoying this
let me enjoy it at the speed i enjoy it
why do you care how fast i eat you know
what i mean this is how i enjoy it let
me enjoy it you're eating dinner with a
snow shovel
psycho
what well seriously i don't i don't sit
there and go you eat so slow
that's crazy if i was like why are you
eating so slow that person would be
self-conscious sounds like a real nice
date doesn't it
you're eating too fat you ain't too slow
i'm done she's asking for parmesan
cheese
she's waiting you're putting a blender
on the table about a shock on the steak
you can't lick with five steak um who
put cookies in his mouth
gang let's talk about bumbas bombas
bumba's mission is simple make the most
comfortable clothing ever match every
item sold with an equal and donate it
so when you buy boombas
you're also given to someone in need yes
bulma's designed their sock shirts
underwear to be the uh the clothes you
can't wait to put on every single day
everything is made soft seamless tagless
and it has a luxurious cozy feel if you
know anything about me and a big man
like a nice luxurious cozy feel yes we
do uh a pair of bomba socks for
everything you do they come in tons of
options if you like comfy comfy
performance styles every sport or
activity that keeps you moving t-shirts
are made with thoughtful designs
features like invisible seams soft
fabrics the perfect weight so they hang
just right
um so far boma's customers like you have
helped donate over 50 million items of
essential clothing damn what are we
doing let's give back baby
let everybody wet their beaks uh go to
bobas.com garbage and get 20 off any
purchase that's b o m b a s dot com
slash garbage for 20 off bomas.com
garbage do it yeah kip let's talk about
athletic greens athletic greens yeah you
need a g1 baby i'm not just a uh what
are we what are an ab monster user
i'm a user kid's an end user i'm on it
got you hooked on the stuff about two
weeks i've been using that green powder
baby absolutely love it i have it every
morning on an empty stomach i take i
take it with my pills i have my pills i
have that if i'm on my way to the gym in
the morning yeah i take it with me to
the gym because i'm telling you i feel a
difference rather than just drinking
water and drinking that throughout my
workout of course it keeps me keeps me
going it keeps me juiced up yeah it's
good for gut health for immunity all
essential vitamins i can't beat it it's
like a carpet bomb for multivitamins
takes care of everything you need best
thing about it uh whether it's it's
lifestyle friendly whether you're keto
paleo vegan dairy feed dairy free
gluten-free the whole nine they got you
covered this is this this this threads
every needle
uh it costs less than three dollars a
day and if you're investing in your
health it's cheaper than your cold brew
habit i mean i'd do a couple cold brews
a day
i'm off to cold brew and he's all he's
an ag one man through and through i'm
telling you i am um they have over seven
thousand five star reviews recommended
by professional athletes trusted by
leading health experts such as tim
ferriss and michael
gervais take that there you go um right
now it's time to reclaim your health and
arm your immune system with convenient
daily nutrition especially heading into
cold and flu season it's one scoop into
a cup of water every day that's it no
need for a million different pills
supplements this that this they got it
all in one shot to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase all you have to
do is visit athleticgreens.com
garbage again that's
athleticgreens.com take ownership over
your health and pick up the ultimate
daily
net nutritional insurance do it yeah i
have a theory okay
um i mean we were raised by human beings
weren't we theoretically
did you watch television when you were
eating dinner as a kid
uh what was the
weekly what was the weekly
i mean we've gone over this a decent
amount for sure uh have we gone over
your weekly where you ate
yeah well it's yeah so i
monday tuesday i was at my mom's
wednesday thursday i was at my dad's
right so
uh depending on the
time
of
my chat like sometimes my mom was
working nights
or sometimes she'd get done at like so
you weren't sitting down eating dinner
usually
no i mean i think that i'm trying to
remember the nights was when i was in
like heist like older because we did but
the tv was always on we always watched
if we were that's what i was getting if
we were sitting down like you also got
to think like
single mom so like
danny had soccer sarah had [ __ ] field
hockey you know i was like seven or
whatever so it was like
um i was smoking bernie's out you had
jock itch
um but like
so between all of that yeah you know
it's like
as you're trying to juggle work cooking
and getting the kids everywhere
all right guys homework it wasn't like
like when we were all sitting down at
the table that's where hamburger helper
comes into the clutch oh yeah if we were
all sitting or applebee's if we were all
sitting down at the table it was off for
sure but like if i was
eating while she was like do it you know
yeah yeah i got you the tv would be on i
would be at the kitchen table to be on
in the family room sometimes it would
turn that off yes then i would you know
yeah on this side so i can see it you
listen to it yeah yeah especially if
like fresh prince or something zone that
was a hot hot track yeah it was uh we
the tv was always on while we hit i
remember being a little kid
and having like a little tiny kitchen tv
that like those i never got like they
wheeled that we almost had like wheeled
up to the table why we ate you guys are
animals
or it was like in the corner of the
kitchen the table was close enough very
comforting though
i guess they're saying there's there's
something psychological in that
relationship of
food
tv sure
that's why i think i eat like that
like an animal yeah i get it yeah well
it's like you don't just enjoy the food
that's sort of it's like you're like
costanza when he gets puts the you know
the pastrami and the tv takes everything
to bed the food the tv and sex
you don't just enjoy the one thing if
you just i think if you were like
like from a place of consciousness if
you were in the moment enjoying the food
it would be slower and you would enjoy
that process myself included maybe
everything's in front of the tv or i got
headphones
your computer is very european when
people eat like that
oh yeah they eat real chill yeah what
are they talking about
they had nothing to say i don't know
world domination i don't know
it's crazy great question though
this is from luigi f baby ever been
struck by lightning
do you know anybody that's been struck
by lightning
yeah i have a friend who got struck by
lightning twice do you believe that yeah
he's gotta be lying about what
yeah i do you believe both of them yeah
well i'm straight struck by lightning i
believe so not like in a boat or my
house because i knew a family
uh
friends of ours their chimney got hit
got struck by lightning and like some
bricks fell but that was it sure not
like yeah you thought it was war of the
world they didn't turn into powder
[Laughter]
they weren't throwing spoons around the
room and no superpowers to speak of what
bozo friend are yours is there if
there's got to be a thing that if you've
been struck once you're probably more
likely to get struck again because
you're like ionized that's exactly
correct
yes it is
that's a what's a one and a trillion
chance i know but you're probably you're
you're electronically different than if
you dude you get zapped by like 60 000
volts up your ass that's crazy turn into
a panasonic yeah [ __ ] tune in tokyo
[ __ ] am fm and hbo go
led over here
yeah there's there is a thing where
you're like fizzy you're like chemically
changed or whatever it's like a dora
cell i don't think so i'm telling you
maybe not t-bone should have had that
right away though
t-bone's been wrong a bunch too in the
recent
yeah yeah it turns out the uk is 14
times oh man dude you got ruined on
patreon for that god i'm an idiot oh man
literally like everybody and you also
said central america was a continent
still a nice place to visit
so apparently no okay yeah no [ __ ] but
this is pretty funny it says well let's
send it it says no
you won't get it it's more likely but a
bit yes because being hit by lightning
often happens to people that have
occupations that expose them to weather
they go imagine you get hit by lightning
deliver in the mail then you get hit
again dude what is your but what does
your buddy do
uh i i storm chaser
[Laughter]
bill paxton yeah
dorothy
i don't even know she it happened to her
like i think she was it was a girl yeah
i i pictured some bozo for sure yeah no
i think they were out in a field or
something twice i don't know but they
definitely got hit by lightning twice
which is [ __ ] crazy
i remember being my step dad's ford
ranger in like a [ __ ] horrible
thunder it was before he was my stepdad
he was just some dude at this point and
i do we were in like the worst storm of
all time and i was petrified were you
driving he was yeah i mean i was like
six i don't know if you were like
sitting in a parking lot no i was in the
back of i was sitting on those fold-out
seats in the back remember those little
like jump seats that were in the back of
that came from the sides yeah
[Music]
and let me tell you the bernies were
flying in that thing he miles of being a
[ __ ] chinook
at that point i remember this [ __ ]
anti-aircraft fire coming through yike
dude it was those things suck it dude
i'm telling that was like one of those
no one's ever lived in in a crash well
also in one of the oh no i probably
didn't have to have the seatbelt on he
had to like move like the [ __ ] you
know the toolbox to get the seat there
empty coffee cups and [ __ ]
there's take a bandsaw and there's also
a thing too when you're that young
you're like i just want like my mom or
do you just want your parents you know
what i mean they're like superman in
your eyes wait why what happened you
start freaking out no i'm just saying i
was just sitting in the back i'm like
two dis this is like the plane's going
down with this guy i don't even know
this [ __ ] dude he was picking me up
from like hockey practice or something
hey man what's your last name again
you might crack in a window
these winstons are killing me never mind
i'll have one
ah that's awesome
that's a tough we were petrified of
lightning the foley's that's what i'm
saying and it's from that he's like now
you're good the rubber and i'll still
use it like the rubber yeah you can't go
you can't you're telling me a car can't
get electrocuted no you're good that's
crazy no the rubber saves you that's
what they always said yeah that's weird
yeah no i don't think that's real i
think it is there's too much metal to
out
there's got a car has to be able to get
a no it just goes through it it conducts
it and it goes through probably where my
hairline is going he's right damn it
foley knows his lighting
you have an obscure paranoia foley's got
the facts
i was actually thinking that i'm telling
you
yeah safest place to be is in a car or
on a bicycle
i think you're pushing it there's no way
or a long steel pole
at the top of the empire state building
which are we called the freedom tower
gets struck with lightning all the time
just goes right through it what
it does it has like a lightning round
book report on lightning recently or
something what the [ __ ]
it was invented by benjamin franklin
yeah discovered not invented
whatever can't invent lightning that's
never been proven
dude you're dropping lightning facts
like you only have the l encyclopedia
let me tell you about lauren michaels
[Laughter]
when you were a kid did you ever do the
science project where you powered
something with the electricity from a
potato we did do something the karen ran
through a potato or something
i made fries
cubby's over there with a [ __ ] baked
potato bar
who wants chives
we need more wiz please i'm in the weeds
over here
we're supposed to make a clock this fat
bastard built his own microwave
jim teacher's gonna think of bacon bits
in his hands
[Laughter]
there you go that's how you went over
the judges
i didn't i feel like i didn't make it
through any of that stuff what i was
supposed to make the planets one time
that was a fight at michael's dude that
was a [ __ ] war you know my times i've
been screamed at being like i remember
how to make like the atom for like she
wouldn't get me all nine plants i'm like
what do you want me to [ __ ] do
i know dude i've been i've been getting
i would get yelled at and michael's
going you waited till the last [ __ ]
second
and michael's
if i'm sure if i smelled that if i
walked into a michaels and smelled of
michaels now would just take me back to
getting screamed at
you gotta stop procrastinating
you [ __ ] eight years old yeah yeah
they were psychos weren't they well
imagine dude i'm so selfish i don't even
like doing things for me imagine what
they come home [ __ ] from imagine you
did this we don't even i mean like we
work you know we work hard but imagine
if you you came from a hard day of
[ __ ] podcasting in the content
factory you get home and then some fat
little kid goes hey mom i got a project
doing the planets in the morning time
it's gonna cost you a hundred bucks in
two hours tonight two at least two yeah
this is all pre-internet so you're like
reading the she got you got your mom
reading the textbook or the encyclopedia
or whatever i remember my mom just
google [ __ ] my mom being so frustrated
with me and like uh this is this might
be a deep cut have you ever seen your
mom erase something when she's angry
buddy this do you know what i'm talking
about my dad when she has the original
no you're doing it
she would dude it would be immaculate
like you can't even there's not even a
trace of lead in there you all might no
do that you're the smell of that too and
clean the cleaning of the cleaning of
the dust damn there's a reason that like
it comes up in uh
it comes up in like all of my siblings
therapy sessions my dad my dad was a
you know as a known wacko and he used to
i guess get caught in like a trance or
what dude he would put a hole in the
paper like out of like anger or whatever
and then if he was helping you with
homework yeah it would go through to the
table and we'd be like whack oh
yeah we'd have to go to like office max
and make like a photocopy of it or
whatever oh it's like the single sheet i
always had to have something underneath
i could never write on just a table
really yeah
or something something
yeah i'd like to have a couple sheets of
loose leaf
gives it a little cushion for me right
with your fists like a gorilla
that's bad it ruined the finish on the
table i told you i realized
i might have mentioned this before but i
really i think my whole family because
they were all there to witness like the
day they realized oh he's dumb
like legit dumb
was uh i was like late for something for
somebody and you re i was thinking this
the other day dude you really are
just dumb i had this exact thought wait
because of this what i'm about to say
no no just because i own a business with
you
i mean [ __ ] [ __ ] doing your [ __ ]
trigonometry homework try to try running
a company i was writing out some book
report like just copying something out
of the encyclopedia
and my paragraph on the paper it kept
it like would would go that way
so by the by like by the end of the page
that would only be two words in the
sentence and it would be completely
slanted and like i remember like
my brother my mom or my dad coming in
and they were like they were all looking
at like what the [ __ ] they knew that
they were just go outside and play in
the mud it's something like it's got
lopsided eyes over here
go tend to the hogs or whatever it is
yeah
that's when they knew they were like
jesus but now why do you think i'm done
what did i do
it's not now it's not
uh
it's not what you do
sounds like something my mom says yeah
but she knows you're dumb as well we've
dealt with you for a long time
um
no i was talking to my wife about
something for the business a lot of
conversation about me with you and this
bird
i don't like it i posted a picture the
other day and someone called her the
bird
[Laughter]
so because there's the bird
the bird's all right that bird's a good
name
where's the bird at
bro it's pretty good too but birds are
right
she doesn't like broad only because i
always say that's dumb broad
like you're stuck because when we're
driving or whatever kind of like i'll be
back ass i'm dumb bro bro it's pretty
good broad's all right hey you dumb
brood kip let's talk about movement
movement baby couple of college dropouts
got into the sunglass game turned it on
its head came through swinging came
through swinging we just they just
re-upped with us i gotta i gotta watch
now you gotta watch they sent us me a
cool pair of sunglasses i have to watch
them last time i love it here's the
thing i'm gonna give you a little tip
right now yeah for all the bozos out
there uh-huh valentine's day is coming
up around the corner score yourself some
gear on movement it will blow him or her
away yeah i'm telling you if you're a
guy or a girl they got you covered
everybody movement is valentine's day
favorite with timeless watches uh 18
kara fine jewelry pieces and special
edition styles like rare ceramic watches
and bracelets my wife's got some your
lady's got some it's fantastic
stress-free takes all the stress uh and
anxiety out of valentine's day by
getting the perfect watch and accessory
for your special someone uh shop 20 off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to
mvmt.com garbage go to mvmt.com
garbage for your most stress-free
valentine's day gifting yet mvmt style
shouldn't break the bank join the
movement baby do it yeah let's talk
about the good people at hello fresh
hello fresh big fans the foley family is
yeah as you know we scored a little bit
of that uh my sister-in-law recommended
we get that from my parents for
christmas home run we got them a nice
subscription yeah hooked them up my mom
loves it yeah i tell you what they do
this one shrimp dish shrimp over salad
almost like a cajun shrimp uh-huh knock
your socks off
knock your socks off it's fantastic you
get farm fresh pre-portioned ingredients
seasonal recipes delivered straight to
your door skip the trips to the grocery
store and count on hellofresh to make
home cooking easy fun and affordable
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit number one it does make cooking
fun when you have everything laid out in
front of you it's fun yeah uh they got
everything it cuts back on time spent
the kitchen so you can spend it on your
others resolutions you have meals
reading around 30 minutes or less plus
quick easy meals including 20-minute
meal recipes low prep easy clean up
provide a faster route to putting the
food on the table got out the middle man
there you go they even got dessert
covered satisfy your sweet tooth with
seasonal limited time goodies like
dunkaroo cookie dough what what or
vanilla delight cheesecake nice i know
you three cheesecake i like a little
cheesecake um like you said we're big
fans of it they sent it to both of us
you got uh you got pat pimeo on it so go
to hellofresh.com garbage16 and use code
garbage16 for up to 16 free meals and
three free gifts what do we want that's
crazy they're giving away the farm hold
on a second one more night you're crazy
we're giving that money away what are
you nuts hello fresh go to
hellofresh.com garbage16 use
codegarbage16 for up to 16 free meals
and three free gifts do it crazy now
back to the show yeah
no we were talking about something i
just go yeah he can
you can't wrap your head around certain
things and i just have to learn to not
try to teach you just go they're done
the job's done i don't need to
incorporate give me an example of what i
can't wrap my head around name one thing
i mean we were just going over the ads i
don't know
like you were saying everything's
confused this was literally like what
are we like 43 this was literally 43
minutes ago you were like hold on you're
confusing me
meanwhile toby's disassembling [ __ ]
luminex cameras and he's got it yeah
all right yeah hey i admit it i'm stupid
they knew from a young age
yeah they knew from a young age i
remember it was a rainy sunday
and it was like they were they were all
really mad at me because i had [ __ ] up
to sunday because i didn't do this paper
or something like that and that's when
they didn't even they all were my mom my
dad my brother why was your brother man
i don't know just kids
like's a nice dog pile
fumble
[Laughter]
get in on the little get on the little
one eating his boogers like lord of the
flies over there i'll tell you man
that's how he operates too there's
always a there's always a good and bad
team that you got to be on no he was mad
because dude you know how annoying i was
to him i mean he would like yeah again i
can pick up on it he would have like his
his grades were always good he would do
his own work he used to go to bed at
like
what'd you get on number eight and he's
like we're not even the same grade
just copying the wrong they just want to
hear something
it just needs something it's a
technicality you just got to show them
something
uh he would like you know he would like
make sure he was in bed he would eat
right he would he would like exercise
before he was like he was a grown man
before he was when he was a kid and then
it was me yeah
yeah the old crooked report
old crooker report following if i get
writing on paper sideways
ah it's good stuff oh man lightning
that's [ __ ] though
um all right this one's from tj ever
have to meet one of your grandma's
boyfriends
that's tough
that's tough i've never you know i get
it especially you know i i never had to
do that
ow it would be some guy named al how do
you take that guy into the family that's
a tough one he drives a cadillac
he drives a cadillac his wife's dead
he's great at pickleball
yeah that's another thing too i want to
add to the list if you play pickleball
you're trash it's something all these
old broads are doing all my all my aunts
and uncles are talking about it
it's like
it's like tennis and racquetball for old
people it's like a big ping pong
it's like a ping-pong court kind of i
like that and there's a lot of moving
around are you standing on top of the
table
no it's on the ground okay well like the
the things like not even the size of
this office
yeah
it's not even the size of the studio is
it outside it's inside or outside and
there's like a little net and then you
play like double so like you don't
you're not like moving a whole bunch i
mean my 67 year old aunt's playing yeah
some of you do that
she's not playing it with federer all
right uh foley picture the rackets you
use on the beach those like solid ones
battle ball i hate that [ __ ] what was
the point of that to keep it up it's a
good game ah 653. try me north wildwood
record come see the [ __ ] kid
where's this hall of fame down there
wildwood dude i love a pure homie stat
oh yeah i've been throwing that around
for about a decade
what six i retired after that 600 back
and forth 653. one two three four five
six who counted
i'll relive the glory days we talk about
your football enough dude that [ __ ] is
the best fight in my paddle and hanging
it on the wall five blocks no hands on
the handlebars that's another big one
made it all the way from sam's to wild
wheels pier
[Laughter]
it was the dead of winter
streets were wide open
and i was all over them you do that
memorial day you're gonna
get up
[Laughter]
fair enough [ __ ]
okay
he really pulled a [ __ ] mouth do you
really pull the e-brakes i'm thinking
about being dumb
well sounds about right
this one's not gonna hit foley but it
should hit t-bone uh
this is from jack ever do ddp yoga
diamond dallas paige was a wrestler and
started this like dirt bag yoga
it's that's a that's that that's a
that's a good one i know diamond dallas
pages yeah so we did ddp yoga i feel
dumb
well you look at this
i feel like four is coming all right
pull out of foleyville we're really
descending in
there we go and we're back
um
all right let's see here
this is from danny dick salad
i haven't had one right that's a good
piece of business i haven't had one read
yet
what are some garbage times guests took
the term
make yourself at home too literal here
no
in your life
i have one that made me think of it
we were in like junior high
and we had this
we we had a group of friends over to
watch the ncaa championship game it was
always on like a sunday or monday night
or whatever
and this kid got invited through like
someone else and he was like he was like
the bad kid now where is this at your
mother's side yeah this is at the
peace's house how old are you
four to thirteen
super bowl no ncaa championship all
right go ahead
man he is in his head
he's recording three different podcasts
right now
it's not lightning out is it
good um
and he got invited he was like the bad
kid like i would i didn't like
associating with this kid so much bad
kid like he got in trouble or bad kid
because there was bad kids that got in
trouble a lot and there was bad kids
that you thought were gonna hurt you he
was both he was the guy who was like
fighting kids dads and stuff yeah you
know what i mean like he was like
fighting men at this point yeah and like
was working construction at like 13 you
know just like
[Laughter]
he was staying at his brother's sister's
hat he was staying somewhere you know
what i mean
sick party i'm gonna take a shower and
tattoo myself
[Laughter]
dude he fell asleep on the couch his 18
wheeler license at 14 cdl cdl
yikes
yeah
he was a kid where he's like let's go
smoke and i'm like yeah we this isn't
just like an open smoking household like
we gotta let you know he was one of the
kids like well i'm gonna smoke i'll deal
with the repercussions i was like all
right you're really making this [ __ ]
just goes out in your back porch and
it's out on the back that cranking
bernie's what i'm trying to play it cool
she's like you sent her to bed i said
hey listen [ __ ] hit the bricks will
you
all right this is like the double deuce
down here
boot knife
falling out
this kid played by his own rules and he
was you know counting he had like pills
he was like counting pills in his pocket
or like loose pills it's never a good
sign
not vitamins
no
they didn't look like barney rubble
the only thing i could think of but he
fell asleep on the couch
and everybody left and i was doing like
ah hey you know because i don't want to
wake this kid up end up in a [ __ ]
chokehold
skip a [ __ ] hem me up too sweet
falls asleep on the couch like sitting
there he lay he laid down he put his
legs up on the couch uh shoes no i think
shoes were off
and passed out and now i'm like uh you
know
just all my friends he was like a friend
of a friend i don't even know this dude
really what day of the week it's like a
sunday night it's every it's a school
night dude
i still got potatoes to cut
i still got prep work on the potato boy
got busy working
okay
so what'd you do
holy [ __ ] i was just trying to like
big game you know like hooting and
hollering and waking them up
and then you kind of finally woke up
around 11 30 or so
[Music]
[Laughter]
my mom was coming back that's the middle
of the night when you're 14.
what the [ __ ]
my mom was coming down is he sleeping
here i'm like get out of here he's gonna
beat you up
he's gonna steal the jewelry yeah play
dead do something
[Music]
you get up and leave what do you spend
the night no he got up and left but i'm
like who's coming to get it was again
picked up by his sister's boyfriend or
it was like it was a
um
it was a thing
my sister's boyfriend's coming to get me
yeah
well that happened a lot and it's not
bad for those kids that happened a lot
in our area because we had a we went to
a really good school district so like
uh
people would do anything they could like
it you know like hey go live with your
cousin go live with the whoever changes
the address so there was
not the end like you know certain
sections weren't uh
they were a little not that he's not
just you know wonky setups yeah
you don't want to end up in some bozo
school district yeah so it was like hey
you know go
stay at your sister's house or whatever
right
somebody was asking uh i forgot i forgot
to mention was hanging out with him at
skankfest does anybody ever die on
vacation
that's always crazy that's a pretty good
one that's pretty good
um this one's great this is from paul
ever cancel one subscription to a
podcast patreon to reallocate those
funds and level up at level up at
another sorry schultzy we're garbagio
now yikes
take that huh yikes [ __ ] you schultzy
got that what
i love you chelsea
yeah right
i'm team schultzy we're hanging the
other night chelsea makes me whack you
i gotta be done i would do it too
the bald guys gotta go
would you kill me
if so if we were if we were like proper
peaky blinders gangsters you can't we're
together we then you can't it's me and
you
we've painted this story where we're
peaky blinders proper [ __ ] gangsters
my enemies are your enemies your enemies
are my enemies
right on the surface
until the heroine gets involved um
no if
if schultz was like the main bad guy and
he was like you gotta go i mean there
would obviously be some plans for me in
the organization oh you [ __ ] but he's
probably just gonna whack me as soon as
i get done killing you that's why he's
got t-bone whacked me t-bones don't now
he'd get whacked too that's what yeah
it's all part of his master plan alex
media would whack him or
gagnon [ __ ] whack t-bone no that's
what you do you make them oh my god have
you never you're you've never watched a
movie or anything you make them think
like you're playing ball maybe say he's
gonna fix my teeth meanwhile me and you
are playing in the bat playing in the
background
but then we go kill him now we're kings
ah
yeah we gotta fake kibby's death dude
yes it's in pinkie blinders ooh fake
kippy's death and a new committed i come
in and i take him out in the end
take his picture that money
[Laughter]
just kidding love you sheltey know what
to do with akash
then he's on a vengeful tear he's coming
for us he'll play ball yeah i can go
backwards i go back with akash really we
go back
sweet we'll see i don't know
nice
all right what are we doing this
[Laughter]
uh never never never and no of course i
would never whack you
i don't know schultz is pretty
convincing though and you are dumb
enough if he came to me and said you did
something or whatever and it's got to be
i could see him talking in a schultzy
way real low you're crazy this is making
what
told me to turn my phone sideways next
thing i know i'm standing
hey do me a favor kill kippy
he's schultzy chaucey says push a button
on the guy you push the button oh
oh we're going to talk about it i'd be
confused we're going to talk about this
and hard feelings right after this i'd
be conflicted about it okay
well whatever you know it is what it is
make sure you have an open casket
unless i miss whoops
it shoots you six times
[Laughter]
all right now of course
um
you're with me now this is from benjamin
first time long time
uh i come from a big family the family
car was an old yellow short school bus
16 passenger we named it the cheese log
we would take it out we would take out
the sleet seats and have sleepovers in
there it was our garbage version of a
tree house
we used to get dropped off in school
with it it was a tough look imagine
getting dropped off at school on your
own school bus
that's bad
in the backyard well how else are you
gonna get those goddamn kids everywhere
too how many kids he said big family i
don't know i mean
yeah eight you don't need a school bus
eight kids yeah that's ten that's ten
people with their parents in what car
puts holds ten people you get like a
suburban or something suburban doesn't
hold ten people well get a regular van
then man
not a [ __ ] school bus yeah which lane
do you pull it you can't pull in with
the civics you gotta go with the buses
yeah you at school you gotta go on the
bus lane
it's okay
a little kid's getting no i think i left
my lunch box in here get out of here kid
that's a private vehicle i do want to
say this private property you're
trespassing other than the wasps and the
bees in the summer which they had to be
brutal if you had that parked in your
backyard in some bushes that's an
eyesore for anybody well if nobody could
see it and you turn i'm saying are you
gary busey
from black sheep
how would i go to your grand your
grandmother's house such a small fire in
her panties
i'm saying from a kid's perspective it
would be pretty cool to have one of
those in the back sure if you took all
the seats out and you did the sleepovers
and it was
your tree fort i get it
but everything else i mean that's just
those are just parents just
doing what they gotta do yeah of course
i mean i'm sure if they had the money to
buy two escalades and tai won't you know
tow the other one
did that dad ever think that he was
gonna be driving a school bus
no at some point that guy was probably
cool
yeah and now he's driving a [ __ ]
cheese log yeah
to school and not getting paid for it
at least pick up all the other bus
drivers make fun of them
damn that's a tough one here comes gary
and his personal [ __ ] school bus
um yeah it's a tough look tough tough
tough yikes this one is my go-to this is
from uh maggie shout out to maggie uh i
like that they're doing this now ftlt
first time long time i love it
these patreon these homies got a lingo
of their own first time long time never
had one read
you ever use a wet paper towel instead
of a vacuum that's my go-to
a wet paper towel yeah i did it this
morning instead of a vacuum uh-huh
no or sweeping or something for what
like on like hardwood or the tile floor
or whatever
oh yeah yeah i did it today
what i typically do is i like dry my
hands with paper towel and then that's
like kind of moist
but still good i gotta get another thing
on the floor and use your foot yeah or
not i mean i've been i can bend down so
i'll bend down and like wipe get the
like what's under if it's like under the
stove or you know if i see some crumbs
or some dust or whatever
sure of course yeah
i do that with the turtleneck
what with the turlet don't say that ever
again the turlet uh-uh the toilet yeah
the commode the turlet
um we have those butt wipes
and if i dribble while i'm peeing i just
drop a couple of those and use my foot
and
clean it up and then throw it in the
thing sure i gotcha yeah
it's a little different because your
call is in the mess
true you ever just use your sock
to do what
wipe up the pee oh yeah if it's not that
bad one little pass with the sack i did
that yesterday also the um on the toilet
seat there was a there was a dribble or
two i just
just [ __ ] then walked around the rest
of the house yeah i don't care yeah
that's true i mean there's dirtier
things in that house
i use the bathmat i slide the batman the
bathmat over it just hold it hold it
there for a second it was that's a
bacteria tram that's jesus christ you
have to turn that thing over to the feds
i got busted peen in the shower
yesterday too
because my move is sometimes i'm like
really well were you in the shower no i
was not oh my god no i was not that's
you come on
i think she's been tracking me because
she she she knows my movements she goes
in you're hanging upside down from your
leg in a rope
i caught you like a
quite like a wild animal
peanut butter in my mouth um
i go in and i turn the faucet on mm-hmm
and then knock open the shower curtain
wait that's a you you can't quietly open
a shower because
you hear it dead giveaway uh-huh she's
like what are you doing
get out of here yeah paying the bills
all right just take the hose and the
shower head and
that's very very unsanitary
is it
i think so yeah just every once in a
while plus your toothbrush is in there
ah i think it's one thing if you're in
there and you're peeing
because the water's flowing it's cooking
that whole time you know true
i do we do a pretty good job of cleaning
the bathroom though i will say that she
does yeah it sounds like there's pee
everywhere you got it
i gotta do something so i keep running
her toes um
all right all right this is from master
rashi first time long time do you cut
your fingernails into an old piece of
mail so that you don't have to use a
napkin
an old piece of mail yeah like i respect
that yeah like i guess the open envelope
is like oh yeah do it and you just throw
it i'm a big notes on the envelope too
oh yeah write down the whole mastermind
for this plan was drafted on a [ __ ]
old parking ticket really yeah
everything's only had enough with the
city huh
everything's on the back of mail because
i don't open my mail now ever i don't
know what's going on with knock it off
uh it's like you know i feel like kramer
and that just you get stop my cable
company mail everything auto paid the
bank what are we doing yeah it's crazy
[ __ ] kick rocks mailman crazy
although we have mailman to listen to
this i get that but not for me let me
opt out oh yeah if there was no mail
what would all the mailmen do there will
always be mail but i just saying i don't
want it i just leave it until like till
my the [ __ ] woman gets so mad at me
because it's full she's cramming stuff
in there oh
that's all it is credit card offers and
[ __ ] mm-hmm con ed bills yeah what
are you doing i got con everything's on
autopay i i've finally deployed my life
i think everything is on autopay i'm not
there yet i mean i'm still that's scary
i'm still walking a tightrope
i'm aware i don't like autopay i'll get
it when i get it
i'll take care of it i make sure i take
one day now and i pay all that's to pay
all the bills to order bills
sunday just like your mother
um i haven't had one right yet is it
garbage with the majority of your
tupperware is the ones that are
pre-packaged sam would meet that the
pre-packaged sandwich meat comes in i
know ludwig yeah there's a couple ludwig
or budwig is this was the company yeah i
mean there's a couple like oscar meyer
has it they all have kill shower farms
is pretty neat
if that's what you're using for your
tupperware i feel like that deli meat
no no no no no you're wrong because the
deli meat is it's it's a double pack i
know but then you take that off and then
put the lid unless you eat the whole
package at one time that's absorbing
those chromosomes no that's through
osmosis i think that's good it's good
for the planet it's good recycle it's
good you're a dirt bag go buy some
[ __ ] time it's like a dollar at ikea
for decent tupperware you know it'll
handle that smell a little baking soda
little bacon soda ikea yeah who the
[ __ ] buying their tupperware like i
mean you're not going to ikea for
tupperware i'm not saying get it i'm
just saying we have it from ikea because
we were like they have a huge [ __ ]
housewares thing have you been to an
ikea recently yeah i have
no okay i got married
i don't know why you want to fight over
this
they got everything do they yeah yeah i
don't trust them over there
i don't i'll stop it ever since they put
a horse in her meatballs i'll stop i'll
stop in for a meatball or two but that's
not about that place
i'm a target man i like a target
ikea they're never close
they're always hot they're always up by
the airport down by the water or
something like that i know it's like
can't you build a little one and they
don't deliver either
crazy they're oh i got a delivery
i got a delivery thing we got to get
into on hard feelings it's
bananas okay i almost fought a guy
really not really
i would have got my ass there was two of
them
um all right let's do one morning we got
a wrapper
up um let's see here
this one
matthew um
do you let your dog sit on your lap when
you drive
which i feel is i wish they would
trap you wish they would what i would i
would love to have that relationship
with my doggy but we don't have that
kind of relationship
she wouldn't sit on my lap a [ __ ]
golden retriever you could have a golden
retriever on
you could it go steering wheel golden
retriever your stomach there's no way
that's going to work
you have to be like a like a 75 ltd
yeah you'd have to have your cdl
but it'd be nice i'm always jealous of
that i don't like that it's like just
drive let the dog sit in the car that's
too much that's like it's dangerous
that's what i'm saying it's like hey
this i'm so important i want to have my
dog here have your dog and have the back
the trunk the side with the roof i don't
care yeah my mom puts him puts her in
the back seat which she has a little
seatbelt that she puts on that's pretty
classy you know what else was what else
was classy as a kid that we never had
like you would put the dog in the trunk
and then have the gate i feel like
people who drove like subaru's had those
remembers like oh yeah the dog gate so
he couldn't jump into the back seat
which i was like that's great he's got
his own little place back there
yeah and it turned to turn like the
trunk of the jeep like
into like a whole thing like a cop car
like it had a divider between the mouth
the back seat you turn the air on back
here
all right let's wrap it up
ah gang we love you make sure you check
out the special check out the splash
guests youtube right now get some
tickies to the shows we're coming we're
coming everywhere so don't worry we love
you and which one am i looking at here i
never know what you're doing you giving
me this one he finds you let the camera
find you that's right i try to go i try
to go off you you do
well a couple of times i'm looking over
here like a bozo and i got this camera i
feel like i'm doing the local news here
gang we love you we'll see you next week
peace